[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID SINGLETON: Good morning.
Hi, folks, and welcome to
What's New in Android Wear.
My name is David Singleton and
I lead the Wear team globally.
It's been a really
busy year for us.
And I'm really excited to be
able to share some updates
on Android Wear 2.0, and
also some of the new watches
that are coming later
this year with you today.
So even before the
Android Wear 2.0 launch,
we were seeing really nice
momentum in this market.
During the holiday
period last year,
we saw 72% growth in
new devices activated
compared to the year before.
And since the launch
of Android Wear,
we've always said
that people should
be able to wear what they want.
And part of this is
the choice that users
have between a host of different
designs and styles of watch.
And we can only deliver
that through partnerships
with iconic brands.
The number of brands
supporting Android Wear
doubled from 12 last
year to 24 this year.
And the choice of
Android Wear watches
has doubled from 23 last
year to 46 this year.
And we've seen continued support
from our consumer electronics
partners.
And now they're joined by
their fashion counterparts.
And this means that
whatever your style,
our partners have
a watch for you.
For example, Tag Heuer
have updated their lineup
with the Connected Modular 45.
It's a really innovative
hardware design,
which means that you can change
everything from the horns
to the bracelet and the clasp.
Another partner
that's refreshing
their lineup this
year is Michael Kors
with their new Access
Grayson and for men
and Access Sofie for women.
I love these watches.
They've done a really
nice job with the design,
and with watch
faces, including one
that lets you put Instagram
photos right there
to see throughout the day.
As well as existing
partners, we're
also welcoming a bunch of
new partners this year.
And we're excited
to see partners
like Movado, one of the
most iconic watch brands,
bringing their
trademark minimalist
designs to Android Wear.
Aside from watch hardware,
we're seeing app developers,
like many of you in the
room and on the live steam,
take full advantage
of Android Wear 2.0.
We know that people
love to stay connected
while they're out and about
via their Android Wear watches.
And our partner
Telegram is taking
full advantage of the standalone
functionality in Wear 2.0.
Not only does the
app work the same way
if you're connected to an
Android phone or an iPhone,
but when you're watch has
a cellular connection,
it even works without the phone.
And so sending
stickers, like you
can see in this little
video, to your friends
has never been easier.
Another great experience made
possible by the rich display
on Android Wear watches
is getting coaching
while you're working out.
So let's take a look at
this app from our partner
7 Minute Workout.
This app's really great.
I really love using it.
It guides you through 12
30-second long exercises.
And you don't need
any fancy equipment.
Just a wall, a chair,
and your Android Wear
watch, and you can use it
to stay fit and healthy.
Another feature that
we added to Wear 2.0
is the ability to have
complication support.
So users can now
select the watch face
that they love the look of and
have the important information
that they care about available
at a glance throughout the day.
Here you can see Robinhood,
the financial investments app,
is showing your overall
portfolio's value right there
on the watch face.
And tapping on
that, if it's maybe
changed in an interesting way,
takes you to their watch list.
You can then tap on
individual stocks
to see their current value
and the trend over time.
So we see that the best
Android Wear apps really
focus on users' needs
and what they care about,
and then play to the strengths
of the wearable form factor,
as you can see here.
As part of the Wear
2.0 launch, we also
announced that the
Google Assistant is now
available right on your wrist.
You can find answers
and get things
done by starting a
conversation with Google.
And we have some
new features here.
So for instance, you
can now long-press
on the crown on your watch and
say, send a WhatsApp message
to Felicity, who's my wife.
And the assistant will deal
with the interface presentation,
message dictation, and deliver
to WhatsApp just the data
that it needs to
complete that action.
So we're testing this
functionality right now
with selected partner
apps, and it's
going to be open to all
actions on Google Developers
in the coming months.
In the meantime, if you
can't wait to get started,
you can develop your actions for
the Google Home and the phone
today, and your actions
will automatically
be adopted for Wear
when Actions on Google
is enabled for Android
Wear coming soon.
No additional work is
going to be required.
And that means that
going forward, as well
as notifications, watch
faces, and native apps,
you have another option to bring
your service to Android Wear.
And we're super excited
about the new capabilities
that this is going to bring.
So in the rest of this talk, Jen
from our user experience design
team will give you an
update on material design
and what we're doing to make
designing and developing
an Android Wear easier.
After that, Griff will highlight
some of the Android O features
that are of particular interest
to Android Wear developers.
And finally, Nancy will
talk about power and what
you can do to conserve battery.
So with that, I'd love
to hand it over to Jen.
[APPLAUSE]
JEN FERNQUIST: All
right, hi, everyone.
I'm Jen and I lead User
Research for Android Wear.
So today I'm going to talk to
you about some of the changes
that we've made to Wear 2.0 as a
result of research and feedback
that we've received
over the past year.
So I'll go over some
design guidelines,
some common pitfalls,
and how we're
working on improving the
developer experience.
To start off, I just
want to say thank you
so much for all of the feedback
that you guys have given us
over the past year on the
Android Wear Developer Preview.
So we've made many
improvements to the platform
as a direct result
of your feedback,
like bringing back theater
mode and swipe to go back.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so today I'm going
to cover three topics--
watch face complications,
Android Wear UI design,
and developer feedback.
All right, so first, let's
talk about complications.
So a quick refresh
of terminology.
A complication is a piece of
information on the watch face
that tells the user something
other than the time.
So like these
highlighted bits here.
So last year at Google
I/O, we introduced new EPIs
to help developers
build complications.
They enable any app
to supply information
to be displayed
on the watch face.
And they also allow
any watch face
to be able to present that
information to the user
in a way that fits its style.
So we found in user
research that people really
like complications.
They like being able to
choose the data that they want
to see at a glance
and which actions
they want to perform quickly.
So here's a series of
watch faces from one
of our user studies.
Now, these are actual
screenshots of watch
faces that participants had
set up after they'd been
using their watches for a week.
So we didn't give them
any instructions on how
to set up their watch faces.
They customized these
all on their own.
And I'll point out a couple
of interesting examples.
So in this watch
face on the bottom,
the user wanted quick
access to their music.
So they set a complication to
launch the Google Play Music
app.
And in this
complication on the top,
the user wanted quick
access to their schedule.
So they've got a
complication to show
the name of their
next meeting, one
to show the time of
their next meeting,
and one to show their
unread notification count.
So in user research, we
also learned something
that frustrates
users, and that's
watch faces that look like
they have complications,
but the data is
actually not editable.
So users quickly
become used to being
able to change the
data on the watch
faces to be whatever they want.
So if you're a
watch face creator,
then don't just display a
static set of information
on your watch face.
Adopt the Android
Wear complication
API to let your users choose
the data that they want to see.
And if you're an
app developer, then
think about what information
that your app provides
that users might want
to see at a glance.
All right, so we learned
that complications are great
and users love them.
So why haven't all watch face
creators implemented them?
The answer that we hear from you
is that it's hard, especially
if you're implementing
everything from scratch.
So watch face developers
have the freedom
to draw complications
however they want,
but that means they have to
handle everything themselves,
including the text size,
position, style, and layout.
So to make it easier,
we've added two components
to the Wearable
Support library--
TextRenderer, which
auto-resizes text
to fit the area
that you specify,
and ComplicationDrawable,
which goes one step further
and completely renders
the complications for you,
if you tell us the location,
style, and size that you want.
Yea.
[APPLAUSE]
And one other thing that
makes it really difficult
to create complications is
implementing the configuration
screen, like this one
that you see here,
which can show the user exactly
where the complication is laid
out on the watch face and
all of the different things
that they can customize.
So to help you
implement this part,
we've created a
watch face setting
example posted on GitHub
that you can take and easily
adopt to change however
you want it to be.
And after coding,
then comes testing,
and so to help you
with that, we've
created an open source
test suite data provider.
So this makes it easy to
check that all types of data
are going to look good
on your complication
on your watch face.
And since it's open
source, you can also
supply your own data if you
want to test for a specific use
case.
And if you want to find out
more about all of these tools,
then go to the Android
Wear UI session tomorrow
where one of our
lead engineers, Oli
will talk about the
Complications API
And walk you through a
bunch of these tools.
There it is.
All right, so the second
topic I want to talk to you
about is Android
Wear app design.
So last year, we introduced
a number of new UI patterns
as part of the Android
Wear 2.0 Developer Preview.
So we've learned a lot from
your feedback in the past year
and we've updated the guidelines
on when to use certain features
and when not to.
So for example, take the
Wearable Navigation Drawer.
So this should be used for
infrequent context changes,
like accessing settings,
logging out, or switching users.
If your app has a small number
of discrete functions, however,
then instead of using
the navigation drawer,
it might be better to use
multiple app launchers.
So say you have a
fitness app that has
two discrete functions--
activity tracking and
historical analysis.
So you can put these
functionalities
under two different
launcher icons.
And so another
question that we get
asked a lot is, how many
launcher icons can you have?
The answer is as
few as possible,
but as a rule of thumb,
we'd say no more than three.
And in addition to those updates
on the material design spec,
we're also launching
two things to help
both designers and developers
build wearable apps.
For designers, we're providing a
sticker sheet on the spec site.
Yeah-- sticker sheet on
the spec site, sorry.
Definitely utilize this,
because not only will it
help you make your
app Wear native,
but it's also much easier
to try out different layouts
and designs in something like
Sketch rather than in code.
And for developers, we're
starting the journey
to open source the
Android Wear UI library.
What this means is you
can expect three things--
consistent and stable
APIs, frequent releases,
and better responsiveness
to feedback.
And if you want to
find out more, please
go to Aga's session
tomorrow on Android Wear UI.
And yes, this is
the same session
where Oli will be talking
about complications.
And last but not least, I want
to mention developer feedback.
So in the past year and a half,
we've periodically sent surveys
to the Wear developer
community trying
to identify the top pain points
to developing apps for Wear.
And so as a result
of that feedback,
we've made improvements
to the emulator,
we've simplified the
API, like in the work
we've done with complications
and the UI library,
and we've adopted more examples
into the Developer Guide
to help developers get up and
running on their projects.
And so we want to continue
to make improvements
to the developer experience.
So if you have any suggestions
on what we can do better,
then please file a feature
request and we will get on it.
And thank you again for all
of your feedback thus far.
And with that, I will
hand it over to Griff.
[APPLAUSE]
GRIFF HAZEN: Hi,
I'm Griff Hazen.
I'm a software
engineer and tech lead
on Wear's Developer Platform.
I'm here to showcase a few
of the new Android platform
features of particular
interest to Wear developers.
But first, I have a general
Wear developer announcement.
Earlier this year, we launched
the Play Store for Wear
as part of Wear 2.0.
It allows you to search for
and install apps directly
on the watch.
We also automatically
suggest apps
to install if the user
has them on their phone.
They also have a Wear version.
Developers upload
their watch app
to the Play Developer
console, just like phone apps.
The same app can include
watch, phone, or APKs
from other form factors
at the same time
using the multi-APK feature.
When the user installs
an app on their device,
Play Store will automatically
select the right APK
to download.
This works great on Wear
2.0, but if your app also
supports Wear 1.0, it
can get complicated.
The old way to do
this for Wear 1.0
required the developer to
embed their wearable app
within their phone app.
When the user installed
the phone app,
the wearable app was
extracted and sent
to the Wear 1.0 device.
This setup caused a
number of complications,
including increased phone APK
size and a coupled release
process.
I'm happy to announce that we're
starting to roll out a new way
to distribute-- improved way
to distribute your app for Wear
1.0.
The new flow, coming
soon, uses multi-APK.
It allows you to distribute
your Wear app the same way
for both Wear 1.0 and Wear 2.0.
When a user installs
your phone app,
if you have a compatible
Wear up in the Play Store,
it will automatically be
installed on Wear 1.0.
This feature is currently
being tested with a few apps.
We'll be opening it up to
all third party developers.
You'll soon be able to stop
embedding your Wear app
with your phone app.
If you're developing
for Wear 2.0 already,
you'll want to make sure that
your app works well on Wear 1.0
if you set a low
minimum SDK level.
All right, now back to my
main topic, which is Android O
and Wear.
The What's New in Android
talk yesterday covered many
of the updates to
the Android platform
for Android O. Android
O also has a lot
to offer Wear developers,
and I'll showcase
a few of particular interest--
notifications, autosizing text
view, and background limits.
First, notifications.
Notifications posted
by phone and watch apps
continue to be a
cornerstone feature of Wear.
Android O has added
a few new APIs
to make it easier for users
and developers to control them.
The most prominent one
is notification channels.
Notification
channels is a new API
to organize notifications
of the same type
so they can be controlled
by the user together.
All notifications in a channel
share the same behavior
when posted, like vibration,
interruption level, et cetera.
On an Android O
phone, when the user
long-presses a
notification, they
can quickly toggle
future notifications
from just that channel.
They can also tap
to get to the phone
notification settings
for that app, where
they can control other channels
and notification behaviors.
Starting with Android
O, all notifications
need to be posted to a channel.
Here's an example
for setting one up.
First, create a
notification channel object
and provide a unique ID,
a user visible channel
name, and an initial
importance level.
Next, set some
optional properties,
like vibration pattern
and description.
And call Create Notification
Channel to create the channel.
Once this is done, you can
start posting notifications
with that channel ID.
The Android Wear SDK
for O does not yet
include a settings
UI for channels,
but the APIs are
available now for testing,
and we'll be providing
updates in future previews.
The next feature
I'd like to cover
is an update to Android's
TextView control
to support the automatic
sizing of text.
Android Wear devices
have small screens.
And real estate and readability
are important considerations.
With user provided
or localized text,
it takes extra care to make
sure the content fits well
on the screen and is readable.
In Android O in the
support library,
TextView has a new
feature that allows
it to automatically
select its text size
to fill the available space.
The screens above show the
same TextView layout adapting
based on the contained text.
This API includes two ways
to control this behavior.
The first is to provide a
minimum and maximum text size
and TextView will select
a size within that range.
The second is to provide
a list of preset sizes.
Here's an example using the
list of preset sizes in XML.
To turn on autosizing, first
set the new autosize text type
property to uniform.
Then provide the
presets by setting
the autosize preset
sizes property
to an array of text sizes.
Both methods can be configured
in XML or programmatically.
And also, previewed
in Android Studio.
The support library has
been updated to include
compatibility on older
versions of Android, including
all Wear versions, so you can
start using this in your apps
today.
My final topic is
background limits.
As our next speaker,
Nancy, will detail shortly,
preserving battery life is
one of the most important
considerations when
developing a Wear app.
We all want to create
responsive and useful apps,
but also make sure
that the device can
last through the day.
Android O brings with it a
number of platform changes
to help accomplish this.
Android allows apps
to run and respond
to events in the background,
but when too many apps
are running or
execute for too long,
it can overly consume limited
resources like RAM and battery.
Background services
and apps targeting
Android O have new
limitations on how long
and when they can execute.
In general, if an app no longer
has a foreground activity
or service running, it will be
considered idle, at which point
all of its services are stopped.
In past versions
of Android, an app
could also register for implicit
broadcasts in its Android
manifest.
This made it a bit too
easy for many processes
to spin up for common events.
This is no longer
supported in general,
but your app can still register
for these events at runtime.
A few best practices to
preserve app functionality.
The JobScheduler and
AlarmManager APIs
can still be used to
run background work
at appropriate times.
There's also a new class in
the support library, the Java
IntentService, which
uses JobScheduler
on Android O and a fallback to
just regular services on older
platforms.
When your app receives a
Firebase Cloud message,
it will also have
a window of time
to execute before
being considered idle.
If you really need to run,
you can start your service
in the foreground.
A notification will displayed
to the user while it is running.
Receiving location
updates in background apps
is another area where there is
a behavior change in Android
O. It was found to be a major
contributor to power issues
with background apps
being allowed to register
for high rates of updates.
In Android O,
background services
are now limited to receiving a
few location updates per hour
instead of having
unlimited access.
As a best practice,
you can switch your app
to use the batch location API.
Your app will still
receive location updates
at a reduced rate,
but each update
can contain multiple
location events.
If your app needs to
continue receiving
a high rate of updates, for
example, it's a fitness app
and you're doing a run, it
can start a foreground service
and continue getting
the faster rate.
This is a brief look
at a few Android O
features relevant to Wear.
There are more detailed
talks available,
for example, the background
check talk by Ben Poiesz,
and there's a notification
talk this afternoon at 4:30 PM.
If you'd like to try
some of these APIs
on a watch form factor, the
Android O Developer Preview
has been updated to include a
new version of the Android Wear
emulator.
Thank you.
And with that, I'll hand over
to Nancy to talk about power.
[APPLAUSE]
NANCY ZHENG: Thank you, Griff.
So hi, everyone.
My name is Nancy and I'm a
software engineer and tech
lead of the Wear Power team.
So over the last year,
the Android Wear team
has been doubling down on
improving the battery life
of the Android Wear platform.
And we've developed a
set of best practices
that we'd like to
share with you today
that can help you improve the
battery life of your Wear app.
To get started, I'd
like to give you
a sense of how much battery we
have to work with on the watch.
So here is a representation of
battery capacity on the Pixel
XL and Pixel phones.
Now compare that to two
of our recently launched
watches, the LG Watch
Sport and Style.
As you can see here,
our watch batteries
are about 1/10 the
battery capacity
of their phone counterparts.
So that's really
not a lot of battery
we have to work with here.
But despite this, Wear
users expect their watch
to last all day long,
because oftentimes,
having a dead
watch on your wrist
can be worse than
having a dead phone
in your pocket or your purse.
But what are some of the things
that use battery on your watch?
Well, one of the key
drivers is the display.
Now, on Android Wear
watches, we have a lot
of different types of displays.
But for the next
couple of slides,
I'm going to focus on an
OLED display as an example.
Now, here we have the power
draw when the display is off.
Compare that to an
always-on display.
And again, compare that
to an interactive display.
As you can see, with
each step, the power
draw increases substantially.
And that means that the
battery life will decrease.
So the takeaway here is that
reducing interactive display
time will save power.
One way to do this is to
reduce the amount of time
that the user has
to spend in your app
by making it quick
and easy for the user
to do what they need and
move on with their day.
Sometimes you might need to
continuously show information
to the user.
And in those cases, you
should implement ambient mode.
So in ambient mode, you
should switch your UI
to a black and white color
theme and only update
the display once a minute.
And this will allow the
application processor
to go to sleep in between
and conserve power.
Another thing you should
consider is using dark themes.
Now, in our
experiments, we noticed
that an all white display can
use up to seven times more
power than an all black
display in interactive mode.
And so if you're writing
a watch face or an app
where you expect a lot
of user interaction time,
you should switch to
using a dark theme.
Now, aside from just
color, animations
are also very expensive.
Now, remember that display power
chart from a few slides ago?
Here's how it looks
with animation power
usage in the mix.
Now, before you panic,
remember that most animations
only last fractions of a
second, and so aren't usually
cause for concern.
It's a different story,
however, if you're
working with a long-running
animation, such as a loading
spinner.
This is why, in Wear 2.0, we
switch our framework loading
spinner from the one on the
left to the one on the right.
The difference here is that
we're only rendering one out
of every three seconds
in our low power spinner.
And just by doing this, we
saw a 3x power improvement.
So if you use the default
framework spinner on Wear,
you will also get these battery
savings, which you should do.
Another example of animations
is with the watch face.
Watch faces that have
a sweeping second hand,
like the one on the left,
uses substantially more power
than watch faces that use
a ticking second hand.
So if a ticking second hand
works with your watch face
stylistically, you should stick
with that one to save power.
Aside from the display,
another major battery hog
is network usage.
So perhaps the
biggest battery issue
that we have on
Wear devices today
is unnecessary
background syncing.
Now, let me give you an
example of an anti-pattern that
could happen.
An app could be periodically
sending data between the watch
and the phone or the cloud.
Periodically, let's
say every 15 minutes.
When the user is not
actively using your app,
there should be no
reason for your app
to be syncing periodically
in the background.
The only exception
to this is if you
need to alert the
user of something,
like a message or notification.
And in those cases, you should
use SCM push notifications.
Having said that, if you really
can't avoid background syncing,
you should at least
try to batch your data.
And we recommend batching
to transfer once per day,
and preferably, when the
watch is on the charger.
And you can do this using
the JobScheduler API.
Now, I have talked a
lot about network usage,
but you might be wondering,
how much of an impact
is it on the battery really?
Well, I'm glad you asked.
Assuming you want to transfer
10,000 one-kilobyte chunks
of data throughout a user's day.
If you do this in one batch,
in one 10-megabyte batch once
per day, you'll use about 1%
of the user's battery, which
is OK.
But if you do not
batch this data
and send this in 10,000
separate batches,
you will end up using
over 100% of the battery
on certain devices.
So the difference
is night and day.
So always batch your data.
Now, another scenario
I want to discuss
is if you have to transfer
a large chunk of data.
An example might be if the user
wants to download some music
or if they want to download
an app from the Play Store,
for example.
If you are transferring
more than a few megabytes,
you should use a high
bandwidth network,
such as Wi-Fi or cellular.
Here's an example of the
cost of transferring data
over different radios.
We have here Wi-Fi,
cellular, and Bluetooth.
So with one-megabyte case,
the difference is not so huge.
But let's look at
what happens if we're
transferring 30 megabytes.
As you can see, Bluetooth
is much more power
intensive than
Wi-Fi or cellular.
So to transfer data
over Wi-Fi or cellular,
you can use the
NetworkRequest API shown here.
Unlike on phones, starting
in Wear 2.0, using this API
will actually turn
on these radios
if they're not already on.
And of course, there is a
cost to turning on radios,
so you should only do this
if you're transferring
a large chunk of data.
In your network
request, you should
include a network callback.
And once a network that meets
your needs is available,
you should get a
callback and bind
to the network
that was provided.
And then you can make
your data transfer there.
And when you're done, don't
forget to release your network
request.
This will allow the
framework to turn off
these radios to conserve power.
So for more examples of how
to use the NetworkRequest API,
you can visit our
Developer Guide
by searching for
Android Wear Networking.
Now, aside from the
display and the radio,
there are also other
expensive features
on the watch that
you might be using,
such as vibration,
location, and music.
I don't have time to go
into all of these today,
but just remember to use
these features sparingly
because they're very expensive.
Also, if you want to debug
your app further and look
at how your app is
doing on battery life,
you might want to try
out Battery Historian.
You might have seen
previous I/O talks
about how to use Battery
Historian to debug your phone
bug reports for power.
As you might have guessed,
Battery Historian also
works great on Android Wear.
So give it a go and let
us know what you think.
Now, I want to mention
one more thing.
In many cases, where
we're seeing a user not
get a full day of
battery usage, it's
often caused by an app doing
some background network
processing or location
processing overly aggressively.
This is why in future
versions of Android Wear,
we're planning to
put further process
restrictions on background
processes and watch faces.
This is in addition to
the Android O background
restrictions that Griff
mentioned earlier in the talk.
And so to prepare
for this, you should
make sure to implement
the best practices
that I mentioned here today
to get ahead of the game.
And always remember to test
your app before you launch it.
So we talked about a
lot of things today.
And just to give a
quick recap, watches
have tiny batteries,
1/10 of phones.
Displays are expensive, so try
to reduce interactive display
time, implement ambient
mode, use dark color themes,
and reduce animation usage.
You should also be
careful with network
and make sure to avoid
background syncs,
to batch your data, and to
use high bandwidth networks
for large data transfers.
And finally, don't forget to try
out Battery Historian for Wear.
And with that, I'll hand it
over to David to wrap us up.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID SINGLETON:
Thank you, Nancy.
So to recap, we're making
complications and Wear user
interfaces much easier to
build, so there's no better time
to get started.
Second, as part of
the Android family,
we're getting a whole host of
new features from Android O.
So be sure to check those out
and test your app, especially
the background limits.
And finally, battery
is really precious,
so please conserve it using
the tips that Nancy presented.
Apart from this session, we have
two more sessions on Android
Wear at Google I/O.
So firstly, we're
hosting office hours
at 5:30 PM today
where you can ask experts
from the team anything
about the issues that you face
or the opportunities that you
see while designing or
developing for Android Wear.
And second, we have that
other session that Jen already
mentioned tomorrow
focusing on the new UI
tools we talked about today.
And we'll go through
in more detail
the new, simpler
complications rendering system
that you can start to
use if you would like to,
as well as the new
Wear UI library
that we're open sourcing.
Thanks for attending this talk.
And if you have any
questions, the presenters
will be over in our sandbox
right after the talk,
and we'd love to
talk to you then.
The sandbox is where you
can see right on this map.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]